oh
subject 106. let's talk about my
unequivocal endorsement for the mk23
pistol a reliable companion in your
quest for unadulterated Annihilation
designed specifically for an offensive
approach with match grade accuracy to
get the job done the mk23 is an
extremely powerful semi-automatic with
unwavering efficiency agency this finely
crafted handgun will demonstrate
imperious gumption as you rip through
the anatomies of unfortunate Horizon
soldiers lurk in the shadows and attach
a silencer or a covert personal
statement alongside your opponents with
a merciless execution that
instantaneously sends them into the dark
abyss
or feel free to dual wield for a more
chaotic approach spray and pray
cultivate your Rage with the mk23
[Music]